ils sont cinquante agents rte en ile de
france spécialisée dans la maintenance
sur ce type d'infrastructure des
interventions sur des pylônes de haute
tension électrique avec des risques
d'accident c'est face à ce genre de
situation que le groupe réseau de
transport d'électricité collabore avec
les pompiers des yvelines des
entraînements de sauvetage en eau des
infrastructures avec l'unité grimpe 78
la figuration bull voyait en visual au
dessus de nous on a un ouvrier le
souhaitent un ouvrier a eu un ouvrier
qualifié qui est sur son baudrier qui
est amarrée d'accord il présente une
douleur au niveau de nageurs il est
conscient il est en contact avec son
équipier qui est au dessus
je veux qu'il soit accompagné d'un
facteur d'accord donc la verticale le
plus simple c'était de faire un système
d'amarrage au dessus de lui
ce qui est une ce qui est facile sur des
structures métalliques comme cela et de
le descendre à la verticale sur son
baudrier accompagné d'un docteur le
grimp c'est le groupe de reconnaissance
et d'intervention en milieu périlleux
des pompiers
ils interviennent pour évacuer des
victimes dans des environnements risqué
ce partenariat entre le tz10 des
yvelines et rt e permet une
complémentarité des spécialités
le principal risque propre à nos
ouvrages c'est le risque
d'électrification du coup les pompiers
sont très demandeurs et on essaye de les
former aux procédures d'intervention
pour qu'ils interviennent en toute
sécurité et de travailler ensemble ça
permet de garantir la sécurité de tous
on peut pas se permettre d'intervenir
sur un pylône ou sur un câble sans être
sensibilisés à ce risque électrique donc
le partenariat rte est important que
cette reconnaissance là que nous on n'a
pas nous après on prend le relais sur la
connaissance cordes hauteur dans les
yvelines l'unité du grimp est composée
de 36 pompiers déployés dans les
casernes du département